aujourd'hui oui la majorité des
influenceurs ont des agents je pense que
c'est très bien d'avoir une agence parce
que l'agence va être équipée justement
juridiquement pour son cadre enfin pour
être encadré nous on voit là par exemple
dans les polémiques la plupart des des
postes qui ont été sanctionnés souvent
ne sont pas reliés aux agences et ça ça
n'a pas été vraiment dit et c'est un
problème parce qu'il faut que ce soit
très clair parce qu'il faut que enfin on
sert aussi à quelque chose et il faut
que les influenceurs le sachent
voilà maintenant
c'est c'est
quels sont les principales dérives
rencontrées je ne parle pas de votre
situation je parle de vraiment dans le
secteur de l'influence quels sont les
dérives possibles des influenceurs des
agents d'influenceurs je pense que il y
a deux types de dérives il y a la dérive
par méconnaissance parce que aujourd'hui
on est vraiment lié que au code de la
consommation mais c'est à la fois très
grand parce que le code de la
consommation est très grand et il faut
être honnête pas tout le monde ne le
connaît par coeur et pas tout le monde
n'a cette analyse je pense qu'il y a un
problème de formation
pour nous tous
donc on essaie de faire du mieux qu'on
peut pour s'entourer et être encadré
maintenant
les influenceurs voilà pour moi doivent
faire des formations pour être
aux personnes parce que tout le monde
peut être influenceur aujourd'hui vous
pouvez avoir 18 ans comme 20 ans avoir
un bac + 5 ou pas avoir de bac du tout
et vous pouvez être influenceur donc
forcément vous n'avez pas la
connaissance de toutes les règles et
toutes les lois
donc il faut il faut les former et
surtout qu'Internet est un milieu vaste
ou vous avez tellement de dérives
tellement de dérives c'est à dire qu'on
a rencontré par exemple alors par
exemple il y a le dropshipping le
dropshipping c'est quelque chose de
légal mais où il y a des dérives
malheureusement il y en a beaucoup plus
que de bonnes que de bonnes fin de
personnes qui sont qui font du
dropshipping correctement donc là ça a
créé beaucoup de problèmes mais quand on
s'en aperçoit bah des fois c'est souvent
trop tard donc est-ce qu'il faut
interdire le dropshipping ou pas ça
c'est pas de mon ressort mais
effectivement il y a eu des problèmes
donc dans les agences après on a décidé
d'arrêter le dropshipping comme ça au
moins on préserve après il y a eu des
gens qui se sont mis tous dans les paris
sportifs après il y a eu le trading
après il y a eu la NFT après il y a eu
les CPF là en ce moment il y a des
choses sur les pare-brise par exemple en
fait il y a j'ai l'impression que sur
internet il y aura toujours des gens qui
sont malveillants qui vont trouver une
faille pour
mettre en application leur dérive à
travers des sites internet et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit accompagné
là-dessus pour
être prêt à ce genre de choses et avoir
des alertes immédiates voilà
de secteurs ou de dérive problématique
dans cette proposition de loi sont
évoquées aujourd'hui des interdictions
oui par exemple celle de la chirurgie
esthétique mais pas comme un meilleur
encadrement de jeux qu'en pensez-vous
est-ce qu'il y a selon vous dans le
marché sur le marché de l'influence dans
le marché de l'influence commerciale des
secteurs des activités à interdire alors
oui je pense alors après faire moi de ce
que m'avait appris la RPP quand j'étais
allé les voir en 2017 la promotion de
chirurgie esthétique est déjà interdite
normalement donc mais je pense que c'est
bien de le rappeler effectivement dans
une règle pour que les influenceurs
soient beaucoup plus
qu'ils aient une loi pour eux parce que
c'est tellement vaste comme je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure le code de la
consommation qui ne le connais souvent
pas par cœur du tout et on peut pas
reprocher ça non plus donc c'est très
bien d'avoir cette règle qui rappelle
ses lois mais à la base s'élo elles sont
déjà faites mais c'est bien de les de
les
rentrer dans une règle exprès pour les
influenceurs je pense que voilà mais oui
il y a des choses qui doivent être
claires aujourd'hui on peut pas
travailler avec un milieu où on est
rempli d'amalgame un coup un coup c'est
légal un coup c'est pas légal on sait
pas il y en a qui tape dessus il y en a
qui balancent les autres il y en a non
il faut que les règles soient
applicables à tous que ce soit les
agences les influenceurs que si les
règles ne soient pas piquées il y ait
des sanctions pour éviter ces amalgames
et qu'il y ait enfin un travail serein
je suis bien placé pour le pour le dire
puisque je suis la première à être
sur les fronts de toutes ces polémiques
malheureusement pointées du doigt à la
place de tout le monde
et personne en prend trop ses
responsabilités donc j'avais déjà il
faut que vous le sachiez aussi alerter
le cabinet du ministre Bruno Le Maire en
2021 parce que le métier c'est c'est
vraiment diversifié et ce qui est normal
ça prouve qu'il est en bonne santé il y
a beaucoup de concurrence de plus en
plus et j'ai senti tout de suite que il
y avait un peu du coup du tout d'une
importe quoi mais comme mon agence était
connue et que entre guillemets moi aussi
bah c'était tout le temps mon nom qui
ressortait partout donc je m'étais
permise d'écrire à Bruno Le Maire en lui
disant voilà est-ce qu'on peut faire un
rendez-vous parce qu'il y a des dérives
il faut mettre des règles en place on a
besoin d'être encadré on a besoin de
peut-être créer une association
interprofessionnelle j'avais tout listé
par écrit ils l'ont reçu puisqu'ils
m'ont répondu
j'ai su récemment qu'à l'époque puisque
c'est eux qui ont communiqué là-dessus
ils ont dit que à l'époque c'était pas
leurs urgences ce que je peux comprendre
aussi
mais bon malheureusement aujourd'hui ben
on est dans un dans un dans une
situation qui est délicate tant pour
nous tant pour les influenceurs tant
pour les agences et tant pour moi
personnellement avec ce que je subis à
côté en cyber-harcèlement donc vous
estimez qu'aujourd'hui il y a nécessité
c'est ce que vous
cadré oui c'est une question vitale pour
moi personnellement là je parle de mon
cas à moi c'est une question vitale et
j'aurais aimé qu'on le prenne en
considération quand je l'avais demandé
il y a quelques enfin il y a maintenant
deux ans où j'avais demandé des
rendez-vous à plusieurs reprises pour
alerter les autorités et pour dire on a
besoin de règles claires pour que tout
le monde les applique et que et que les
personnes qui sont responsables soient
condamnées il y a pas de sujet voilà
c'est
bien qu'il faut structurer tout à fait
professionnaliser
ce que vous avez d'autres préconisations
pour justement mieux encadrer
j'ai donc
j'ai créé la fille il y a quelques temps
effectivement parce que dans la loi il
n'y a pas de oui c'est la Fédération des
influences et les créateurs de contenu
parce que c'est quelque chose donc
j'avais soumis l'idée aussi par écrit en
2021 quand j'avais écrit au cabinet du
ministre parce que je pense qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une une un groupement il
faut que je pense que tout le monde
travaille ensemble on vient tous
d'univers différents c'est ça aussi la
magie des réseaux sociaux c'est qu'il y
en a pour tout le monde c'est la
diversité des réseaux sociaux il y a des
gens qui ont comme je vous l'ai dit tout
à l'heure une culture plus importante
que d'autres il y a des gens qui sont
plus expressifs que d'autres il y a il y
en a vraiment pour tout le monde
et donc il faut pas sous-estimer les uns
ou les autres il faut que tout le monde
travaille ensemble pour créer des règles
et il faut accompagner les influenceurs
il faut que les agences aussi soient
accompagnés et ces formations qui ne
sont pas dans la loi par contre et ça
c'est dommage elle elle soit presque
obligatoire et surtout moi j'avais eu
l'idée donc je vais le faire dans la
fille mais je pense que ça aurait été
bien de le faire avec l'aide de des
députés c'est de créer comme un code
de bonne conduite des influenceurs comme
peuvent avoir certains métiers voilà il
y a des ordres de dans certains métiers
parce qu'on a des responsabilités
aujourd'hui qui sont prouvées donc
où on peut avoir par exemple des
avertissements ça peut arriver de faire
une erreur on est des êtres humains
influenceurs est en être humain il faut
pas l'oublier donc on peut faire une
erreur une fois deux fois trois fois
mais quand vous avez un influenceur qui
fait systématiquement les mêmes erreurs
alors que il a les formations alors
qu'il a les informations là c'est plus
une erreur et là il faut qu'il y a une
radiation et c'est pour ça que les que
les les
autorités les agences travail
étroitement avec les plateformes
pour qu'il y ait un apaisement de la
situation et que ce soit sain et que
tout le monde travaille dans de bonnes
conditions je reviens sur votre votre
initiative de créer la ficque où vous en
êtes concrètement en fait de cette
fête-là mon numéro d'immatriculation que
de ce qui a été déposé il y a un petit
moment maintenant donc ça va pas tarder
j'ai déjà plus d'une centaine à ce jour
d'accord de principe de d'adhésion
d'influenceurs j'ai demandé aussi à
quelques lanceurs d'alerte j'ai demandé
à des avocats aussi
pour que tout le monde puisse travailler
ensemble et qu'on puisse construire
quelque chose de propre
autre question et je suis entourée de
collègues surtout n'hésitez pas si vous
avez des questions sur sur la
différenciation entre le canal de
communication commerciale
entre celui les réseaux sociaux et puis
les autres canaux de communication tels
que la presse la télévision etc est-ce
que selon vous il faut distinguer les
règles applicables dans ces différents
communications est-ce que le canal de
communication des réseaux sociaux pour
vous doit avoir un traitement différent
oui je pense qu'il doit avoir un
traitement différent parce que déjà
encore une fois on a pas les mêmes
règles ce n'est pas légal aujourd'hui en
télé par exemple quand vous faites une
pub en télé vous faites appel à des
mannequins donc ils ont un script à
réciter une tenue à voir un endroit
enfin c'est un tournage alors que en
influenceur et c'est ça le rôle d'un
influenceur et c'est vraiment une
différence légale importante que m'a
appris la RPP au départ quand j'ai
commencé et que j'explique à mes
influenceurs c'est que l'influenceur
doit être libre de son contenu c'est à
dire que je ne peux pas exiger un
influenceur voilà tu dois faire ton
poste à telle heure tu dois dire ça
exactement tu dois en fait ce n'est pas
un mannequin c'est pas du tout de la
même la rémunération n'est pas la même
ça n'a rien à voir donc il faut séparer
ça et surtout il y a un élément
important c'est que en télé par exemple
vous ne pouvez pas aujourd'hui passer
une publicité en télé sans qu'elle soit
validée par la RPP alors forcément il y
a pas de problème en télé aujourd'hui
mais si ils ont mis cette vérification
au départ elle a bien été mise à un
moment donné cette vérification c'est à
dire que une marque qui paye une pub en
télé ne peut pas être diffusée si elle
n'a pas la validation de la RPP donc
c'est qui savent très bien qu'il y a des
problèmes et qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
validation
juridique on va dire avant diffusion
pour pallier justement à des des et en
influenceur non c'est-à-dire que nous on
est totalement libre personne ne nous
valide quoi que ce soit alors c'est très
bien qu'on est influenceur mais ça
prouve aussi que on a peut-être besoin
d'avoir des des codes beaucoup plus
clair et des des explications beaucoup
plus claires peut-être des validation
peut-être travailler il y a il y a un
souci dans notre milieu où il y a
je dirais comme un
vous savez comment comment je peux
exprimer on prend de haut certaines
agences on prend de haut certains
influenceurs et du coup on ne nous tend
pas la main on ne nous aide pas on aide
d'autres alors que chez nous par exemple
on a des gens qui ont des millions de
followers donc qui ont un impact qui est
immense et on doit être traité comme les
autres c'est pas parce que une personne
influenceur a fait de la téléréalité que
il ne doit pas être traité de la même
manière que les autres et ça c'est un
vrai problème dans ce milieu aujourd'hui
l'initiative parlementaire cette PPL
exprime quand même la prise en compte
très claire d'un phénomène qui n'est pas
si récent que ça vous l'avez rappelé et
en effet répond en tout cas à certaines
questions ou difficulté que vous évoquez
je vais donner la parole à mes collègues
va se présenter et vous se mettra ces
questions
je suis sénateur d'Ille-et-Vilaine je
voulais vous poser une question parce
que il y a l'agent il y a un contrat il
y a un influenceur
pour bien voir où on peut peut-être
avancer vous dites que l'influenceur
n'est pas un mannequin et donc il a une
grande liberté
et dans ce cas là où est-ce que où est
la responsabilité lorsqu'il y a des
choses qui sont contraires qu'on
pourrait appeler je sais pas comment on
peut l'appeler mais une espèce d'éthique
de la publicité où est la
responsabiliser chez l'influenceur ou
est-ce qu'elle est chez l'agent comment
vous voyez comment on pourrait
construire ça alors moi je pars du
principe ou une agence doit servir à
quelque chose et j'ai pas d'intérêt à
vous dire ça mais je vais je il faut
être honnête si on prend une commission
sur les influenceurs c'est aussi parce
qu'on doit leur apporter quelque chose
donc je pense que cette aide juridique
est importante c'est à dire que si on
donne un placement de produit frauduleux
à un influenceur l'agence doit aussi
être responsable et c'est pas dans mon
intérêt de le dire mais c'est une vérité
et c'est une réalité l'agence si elle
donne un placement elle doit être aussi
responsable influenceur aussi
responsable parce que c'est trop facile
de dire c'est l'agence c'est l'agence
moi je sais que on a eu des influenceurs
qui nous ont dit moi je fais tout et
n'importe quoi et puis on a des
influenceurs qui nous ont toujours dit
non ça je ne fais pas c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'on fait nous on propose aux
influenceurs les sites internet donc on
les valide d'abord au juridique ensuite
on les propose aux influenceurs et les
influenceurs disent oui ou non ils ont
une totale liberté sur ce qu'il propose
donc si l'influenceur n'a pas envie ou
ne se sent pas de présenter ce produit
là il a la liberté de dire non mais si
il dit oui et que il se trouve que c'est
un placement frauduleux alors dans le
cas où l'agence parce qu'il peut aussi
que l'agence était trompée ça nous est
arrivé aussi ou on a vérifié le site il
était légal tout était carré les
conditions générales étaient parfaites
tout est nickel vous faites la promotion
de ce site et le site ferme une semaine
après dans ces cas-là qui est
responsable l'agence qui a tout contrôlé
où tout est nickel ou le site internet
qui est venu dans la volonté d'arnaquer
les gens et y compris l'agence puisqu'on
a même pas été payé non plus des
prestations donc je pense que à ça
doivent servir aussi des enquêtes et des
agents et des des enquêtes de la DGCCRF
ou si on promotionne un site qui n'est
pas
juridiquement
légal il y a une responsabilité de
l'agence à avoir voilà mais si le site
est légal après on peut pas non plus
être derrière la tête des gens enfin
derrière la tête de tout le monde c'est
pas possible c'est c'est clair voilà
mais il faut qu'on propose des sites
carrés voilà et chacun doit assumer ses
responsabilités
passez bien répondu à votre question
ça permet de cerner aux parties mais
chacun ses responsabilités justement il
y a un moment il faudra trouver qui
assume quoi ça c'est je pense que si
l'agence donne un placement de produit
qui est pas légal l'agence est
responsable voilà très clairement c'est
c'est moi je suis si jamais si par
exemple j'ai un de mes influenceurs qui
est condamné pour un placement de
produit que je lui ai donné à faire et
que il m'a fait confiance et bien je
trouverai ça normal que l'agence par
exemple paye sur maintenant si c'est
l'influenceur qui fait en placement de
produit qui n'est pas passé par l'agence
moi je n'ai rien à voir là-dedans voilà
je dire petite question
vous allez aborder le public des jeunes
au début de votre propos
public forcément beaucoup plus
vulnérable
comment voyez-vous la relation des
influenceurs et des agences
d'influenceurs par rapport à cette au
mineur mais je pense que encore une fois
dans une dans une influence commerciale
on ne doit pas s'adresser aux mineurs
vous voyez ce que je veux dire déjà à la
base c'est comme et là je vais comparer
ça à la pub à la télé c'est pareil vous
avez de la pub à la télé il se trouve
qu'il y a des jeunes aussi qui vont
regarder la pub à la télé et qui vont
peut-être vouloir acheter le produit qui
vont voir la télé comme ils vont ils
vont le voir aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux donc on peut pas non plus être
derrière tout le monde ça sera c'est pas
gérable mais
dans l'influence commerciale qui est
différente de l'influence on va dire de
de
notoriété de conseils etc c'est deux
choses différentes l'influence
commerciale et l'influence non
commerciale dans l'influence non
commerciale il faut que chacun fasse
attention à ce qu'il dit sur les réseaux
parce qu'effectivement ça a des
conséquences on s'en est rendu compte à
plusieurs reprises beaucoup plus qu'on
peut le croire et je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention effectivement à ce
qu'on dit ou à ce qu'on fait sur les
réseaux sociaux ça c'est c'est une
certitude maintenant dans l'influence
commerciale encore une fois
on s'adresse pas aux jeunes et encore
moins aux enfants qui normalement enfin
je dirais à quelqu'un un enfant de 12
ans on n'est pas censé avoir peut-être
une carte bleue pour pouvoir on peut pas
être responsable non plus il faut que
tout le monde soit un petit peu
responsable aussi à ce niveau là
de la Somme moi je m'interrogeais avec
ce texte cette PPL notamment sur le
volet en 1 sur les voilà les bandeaux
qui seraient imposés comme quoi c'est
une publicité etc déjà avoir votre avis
parce que je sais qu'il y a déjà des
peut avoir des problèmes techniques sur
le changement quand on change de canal
et de réseaux sociaux je sais qu'il peut
avoir des problèmes juste purement
esthétiques pour faire apparaître ce
porno mais ça ça je pense que les
plateformes vont aussi évoluer en ce
sens mais au-delà de tout ça je
m'interrogeais aussi sur le le notamment
le bouquin de
Delphine de Vigan sur les enfants sont
rois je sais pas si vous vous voyez
c'est une femme qui justement qui se
lance influenceuse et qui embarque ses
enfants dans cette aventure c'est-à-dire
que ces enfants sont filmés H24
et à la fin il y a une espèce de conflit
dans la famille à partir de ça parce que
les enfants ont rien demandé disons
après ils se rend compte que
effectivement ils sont passés dans dans
différents canaux réseaux sociaux ils
ont rien ils ont rien demandé à personne
et pourtant c'était j'ai envie de vous
dire le gain de pain de de la famille en
question donc sur ces sujets pour
rebondir un peu sur la question de mon
collègue c'est vrai que sans le vouloir
une influence un influenceur ou une
influenceuse même si elle a 25-30 ans et
qu'elle embarque
indirectement ses enfants là-dedans
est-ce qu'il y a une pas aussi quelque
chose à
réglementer encadrer en particulier je
pense que les agences n'ont pas à
prendre ce type de profil
ne doivent pas prendre les enfants et ça
c'est quelque chose aussi qu'on a mis en
place c'est à dire que dès qu'on a une
marque qui demande une promotion où les
enfants doivent intervenir ça doit
passer par une agence de mannequin
spécialisé pour les enfants c'est à dire
que nous on ne peut pas encaisser les
revenus dans d'un enfant ça c'est ce que
nous nous faisons en tout cas chez shona
even après je sais pas pour les autres
agences
mais effectivement mais il faut faire
attention moi les enfants c'est quelque
chose pour moi qui est vraiment
spécial et qu'il faut gérer d'une
manière totalement différente et qui ne
doit pas du tout être géré la même
manière que un financeur adulte c'est
une évidence et je rejoins totalement
voilà et là ils en ont parlé dans le
texte de loi je crois qu'ils ont mis
quelque chose là-dessus et c'est très
bien mais quoi qu'il avant nous les
enfants ça nous est arrivé je crois
peut-être quatre fois en presque 7 ans
d'avoir des demande pour les enfants et
systématiquement on a passé ça à une
agence de mannequins spécialisée pour
enfants donc qui encadrent vraiment bien
l'enfant sur les avec la loi qui va avec
en fait voilà et puis un autre point
tout à l'heure je vous disais je vous
parlais du bandeau qui voilà des espèces
d'encadrement là-dessus
il y a des choses qui va qui est en
train de se faire discrètement c'est en
fait
beaucoup d'influenceurs voyant que ça va
comment le marché va être un peu près
encadré par ce type de VPN avec le DSA
d'Emma etc
il rentre en discussion avec les
personnes donc c'est beaucoup moins je
vous l'accorde industriels que des
vidéos qui sont vus par des millions de
personnes mais ceci dit il rentre en
discussion donc en privé avec les
personnes créer un lien et derrière
vendre les prestations
et donc ça bon c'est compliqué à
encadrer je vous l'accorde mais est-ce
que c'est pas est-ce que c'est pas ça ce
qui va se passer c'est à dire que
beaucoup d'influenceurs vont basculer ce
genre de méthode
je on peut faire le test si vous voulez
je il suffit de suivre quelques
influenceurs 48 heures après vous pouvez
éventuellement peut-être ça dépend votre
propre niveau d'influence aussi
avoir une discussion juste pour essayer
de vendre une prestation ou une la
crypto monnaie la copie de trading etc
etc
on en fait pas donc je suis pas dans ce
domaine là et et je le maîtrise pas et
ça ne m'intéresse pas parce que c'est
quelque chose que justement je pense que
je ne maîtrise pas et aucun conseil à
donner là-dessus et je pense que mes
influences non plus donc maintenant
c'est plutôt dans ce genre de choses où
vous allez effectivement sur les comptes
telegrammes etc ça c'est c'est un autre
type d'influence mais c'est pas quelque
chose qui nous enfin qui me concerne moi
parce qu'on fait pas on fait pas ça
enfin je parle via l'agence show nevens
ça n'est pas le cas
nous on fait des promotions visibles sur
les réseaux sociaux où on parle d'une
marque on parle d'une expérience avec
une marque on parle d'un produit
voilà on donne un avis on montre comment
ça fonctionne et on met le hashtag
sponsorisé sur chaque story alors au
départ on le mettait pour être
transparente avec vous on le mettait au
moment de mettre le code promo et on
était une des seules agences à le faire
depuis 2017 parce que comme vous dites
comme là tout le monde se rend compte
qu'il va y avoir des règles tout le
monde se met à le mettre partout et tant
mieux c'est que ça marche donc mais on
nous tape souvent dessus nous shonven's
mais nous étions les premiers depuis
2017 à mettre le hashtag sponsorisé et
maintenant il va faire le mettre sur
toutes les stories qui conc la promotion
et non pas que au moment du code promo
et il ne faut pas et ça il faut être
clair avec les influenceurs parce qu'il
y en a certains qui qui comprennent pas
et qui mélange encore un peu ça c'est
que certains mettent le hashtag add mais
le hashtag add ce n'est pas pour la
Communauté française parce que c'est pas
français donc un consommateur n'est-ce
pas censé savoir ce que ça veut dire add
il faut mettre vraiment hashtag
sponsorisé moi c'est ce que m'avait
conseillé aussi la RPP pour que ce soit
clair transparent et pas en tout petit
cachet dans un petit coin il faut que ce
soit visible voilà une dernière question
je m'interrogeais sur le votre
définition tout à l'heure entre à votre
volonté de différencier les mannequins
et les créateurs de contenu
[Musique]
vous surfez aussi là dessus dans cette
dans cette vision là je suppose mais moi
je m'interroge quand même sur
le les limites de cette définition parce
qu'en réalité
un créateur de contenu quand il fait de
la publicité il a l'obligation de sortir
un slogan en lien avec la on va dire la
pub qu'on l'oriente en tout cas le
produit qui va vendre donc il y a quand
même le slogan la marque qui sort donc
il sent avoir un script tout fait etc
mais
peut-être qu'il crée son on va dire son
son univers et mais à la fin il finit
par le slogan de la marque pas forcément
mais
alors je vous explique on reçoit comme
ça moi vous le savez on reçoit des Brice
des marques on les transmet aux
influenceurs mais le brief n'est pas une
obligation c'est à dire que le brief
c'est juste on l'envoie aux influenceurs
il s'en inspire et ils font le contenu
qui veulent c'est pour ça que des fois
on a des litiges avec des marques qui
nous disent l'influenceur n'a pas
respecté le brief mais il n'a pas
respecté le brief l'influenceur il peut
s'inspirer du brief mais il le fait à sa
manière et c'est ça souvent que même les
marques ne comprennent pas parce que les
marques elles se disent on veut le brief
et alors des fois on a eu des soucis
avec des marques finalement je vais pas
vous payer parce que vous n'avez pas
respecté le brief mais nous le travail a
été fait parce que l'influenceur a parlé
de la marque à sa manière comme il
entendait pas le droit de lui dicter un
code à tel point de dire je ne le paye
pas ce n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
c'est pas ça en influence un influenceur
il doit être libre donc effectivement on
envoie des briefs mais l'influenceur a
le droit de juste s'en inspirer et de
faire à sa manière et c'est là où il y a
une différence avec le mannequin et s'il
n'a pas envie de dire la phrase de A à B
et ben on peut pas l'obliger à le dire
et la marque dans ces cas-là doit faire
appel à un mannequin
voilà
dernière question
dans nos échanges et souvent évoqué la
situation des influenceurs qui résident
hors de France qui s'adresse à un public
français et d'ailleurs dans la
proposition de loi il est évoqué en fait
un contrat qui serait soumis en fait au
droit français
qu'en pensez-vous est-ce que vous vous
travaillez avec des influenceurs qui
résidents de France oui tout à fait je
travaille des influenceurs qui résidents
à l'étranger
il y a quelque chose aussi de très fort
sur les réseaux sociaux comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure par rapport à
l'âge par exemple c'est aussi vous avez
la cible un influenceur il a des
statistiques et dans ces statistiques
vous pouvez voir si la majorité de son
public est français vient de quel pays
en fait on a ces éléments là qui sont
visibles sur les réseaux sociaux donc si
effectivement la majorité des influences
des des followers sont français
évidemment pour moi il y va du bon sens
qu'effectivement ça s'applique au droit
français voilà donc
je pense que c'est un peu logique à ce
niveau là
est-ce que vous avez d'autres éléments
d'autres à ajouter dans le cadre de
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
je pense que c'est cette proposition de
loi elle est elle est très bien je pense
qu'il manque dedans vraiment des des
éléments sur les formations
alors il y a la RPP qui a créé un
voilà un certificat mais le certificat
on va le passer une fois et comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure internet
est un monde grand vaste et avec plein
de de mauvaises pensées c'est à dire que
comme je vous l'expliquais il peut y
avoir ça va être ça puis après ça va
être une arnaque après une autre arnaque
ils ont l'esprit très vif donc je pense
qu'il faut avoir une déformation en
continu et pas des formes juste un
certificat il faut vraiment encadrer les
influenceurs en continu et leur
apprendre
et les alerter et les sensibiliser sur
les nouvelles les nouvelles fraudes
parce que c'est toujours on a
l'impression après c'est ce que moi
remarquer pendant ces 7 années
d'expérience c'est qu'en fait c'est
c'est voilà c'est le drop le paris
sportif après ça s'arrête le pari c'est
le trading après le trading ça s'arrête
c'est la NFT après la FT ça s'arrête
c'est le CPF on s'est peut-être un peu
tous fait avoir dans plein de choses
mais je pense que si on était alerté
aussi
ça nous le CPF par exemple on a on en a
parlé sur nos réseaux sociaux comme
comme quasiment beaucoup d'influenceurs
on peut pas cibler que les enfants sur
téléréalité parce que ça c'est mensonges
il y a énormément d'influenceurs qui ont
parlé de CPF de tout milieu et
nous on a eu enfin moi j'ai entendu
auprès d'une personne
qui travaille un peu dans les autorités
attention il y a des sujets sur les CPF
nous on a entendu ça déjà au mois de
Janvier Février l'année dernière quand
on a entendu qu'il y avait des sujets
sur les civettes ça veut dire qu'il y
avait des gens qui étaient en train
d'abuser et bien on a stoppé l'argument
commercial CPF avant même toutes les
polémiques on a fait un une alerte à
tous nos influenceurs en disant
attention ne plus parler de CPF on veut
plus que CPF soit un outil sur un
argument commercial donc ça on l'avait
fait bien avant et on l'a prouvé
d'ailleurs on a donné tous les
justificatifs à la Caisse des Dépôts etc
bien avant les polémiques parce que on a
eu connaissance mais si tout le monde
avait une connaissance de ça peut-être
que finalement tout le monde aurait fait
la même chose ça aurait permis peut-être
d'éviter certaines choses donc il faut
des formations en continu je pense
ça changera beaucoup de choses merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci en tout cas
de vous être rendu disponible merci à
vous
merci